you talked a little while ago about the
19 year old entrepreneur yes the biggest
asset is patience yes what is the old
entrepreneur what should they have as
their assets on the patient three years
ago I started a business with some other
some other guys we're now 80 people
turning over 10 million pounds amazing
no patient one more
absolutely is fantastic this is amazing
my biggest asset now well I think your
asset is experience all the cliche stuff
it's just cliche it's you know everybody
said it what I think though is do I
think instead of saying experience I'm
gonna tweak it a little bit do I think a
46 year old man has a better chance of
knowing himself than a 19 year old man
yes I do
I think we've all gone through it right
even think about you know transition
from high school to universally you just
get there right you get more comfortable
with yourself ii get more comfortable
with yourself you start being more
honest with yourself to do that so at
this point in your life in my life and
you're like we should really know
ourselves and so what when I hear it's
an even interesting for me to hear that
you started with a couple other
gentlemen to me my hope for my own kind
of like personal picture that I'm trying
to paint here is that the three of you
had some crossover skills but you're all
maintaining your core skill and that's
what's helping the business right you're
taking care of this that person would
Stevie Taylor that and the other
person's there that's a very common
thing for older entrepreneurs because at
that point they've shed their wants and
their romance about being the best sales
guy or the best sales girl and now they
know I'm really good at CFO finances
I'll never let us go out of business
I've got the numbers don't worry guys
you go be crazy cuz I'm gonna make sure
we pay our bills you go make sure the
staff loves us and now we've got this I
was gifted that I do a lot of the
principles well all of them finance
probably being my weakest it's probably
the one that's most commoditized and
when you're in business with your dad
and your brother if they steal from you
it's a good story right so so I think
that um I think that your biggest
advantage is that you got it's probably
the narrative to why you were succeeding
now the question becomes a more
interesting one I'm gonna take you in a
different place that's probably more
grounded in the actual like energy I
think the big thing now at this point in
your life is to really try to figure out
very
what you want to happen and the problem
is you have two other people that may
want different things but if you're able
to align that you guys want to sell the
company soon because that's some real
cash out on that kind of revenue then
all of your behaviors have to go in that
direction you have to figure out who you
can sell to you have to start becoming a
media company to them one of the great
misplays of brand is if I wanted to sell
vaynermedia tomorrow it would happen in
30 minutes not on revenue on the fact
that I would market to the people that
could actually buy me
I don't think Martin Sorrell knows who I
am in 20 minutes he would want to rip
his arm off to buy us that's what I'm
good at
so what I would love to know is how
aligned are you guys and if you're
aligned make all your actions go in that
direction
that's interesting to me right that's
where you can really make something
amazing happen so I think that's
something to really give some serious
thought to but I think it's it's self
awareness at this point you could you
could you've got so much more history in
your 20 30 years of entrepreneurship
that allows you to and and you should
shed even whenever whenever pride you
have left in principles that you don't
bring to the table as well as you know
partners so the more you can shut down
to only focusing on what you do mean AJ
are so efficient because we do not
discuss the things that we know the
other person is better at we don't even
talk about it you know
big and when one broaches the subject
the other gets pissed right because like
why would we even waste time you know
I'm better at this than you and we've
become efficient like [ __ ] [ __ ]
efficient you know and time is the asset
so why do be got it yeah that's great
and the other thing I will tell you I
would highly recommend you forcing your
other two partners to over communicate
with the three of you at all time like
force communication right now you're
successful and you're at this age this
is an interesting time like force
communication anything that you think is
sitting in your heart that needs to be
talked about with your other two
partners I would tell you do that
tomorrow
the quicker you get it out the better
you're gonna be welcome